Wie gesund ist Milch?
Welche Risiken haben die Tabletten,
die mein Arzt mir gegeben hat?
Welche Maske schützt vor Covid-19?
Welche Hantelübung
ist die beste für starke Bizepse?
Wer weiß sowas?
Klar: das Smartphone!
Kann das Netz uns helfen,
gesünder zu leben?
Zunächst ist ja mal festzustellen,
dass der freie Zugang zu freien Informationen,
insbesondere zu Gesundheitsinformationen,
zu begrüßen ist.
Sich mit Informationen auszustatten,
sich neuem Wissen zuzuwenden,
bleibt am Ende immer ein Wagnis –
in allen Lebenskontexten.
Wer mit Hilfe einer großen Suchmaschine
Gewicht abbauen möchte,
findet alleine auf Englisch
rund 100 Millionen Ergebnisse.
Und wer Pickel loswerden möchte,
bekommt bei Youtube tausende Tipps.
Hier kommt es eben darauf an,
genau einschätzen zu können:
Woher kommt der Content?
Wie wissenschaftlich fundiert
im Falle von medizinischen Informationen
ist ein solcher Inhalt?
Und letztlich liegt das dann wieder auch
in der Verantwortung des Einzelnen.
Die private Bertelsmann Stiftung in
Deutschland hat über 1000 Personen befragt,
wie sie bei der Suche
nach Gesundheitsinformationen
im Internet vorgehen.
Ergebnis:
Viele gehen davon aus,
dass die Treffer nach Relevanz
oder gar Aktualität sortiert sind,
und schauen sich nur
die ersten Ergebnisse an.
Wir sehen in den Top drei
einer Suchmaschine meistens die Inhalte,
die eine hohe Reputation genießen,
damit aber nicht automatisch wahr sind.
Trotzdem können Suchmaschinen
natürlich nützlich sein.
Sie sind das Tor zur Welt
der Gesundheitsinformationen für viele,
denn ohne Suchmaschinen wären dann auch
die guten Informationen schwer auffindbar.
Doch wie geht man vor,
wenn man verlässliche Informationen
im Netz finden will?
Ziehe ich eine Internetseite mit mir gefälligen
Gesundheitsinformationen zu Rate,
sollte ich über das Impressum
hinaus schauen:
Mit wem habe ich es eigentlich zu tun?
Wer ist der Herausgeber der Informationen
und welche Motive leiten ihn,
Gesundheitsinformationen
ins Netz zu stellen?
Eine Anlaufstelle für
gute Gesundheitsinformationen
sind Patientenverbände, die sich
vielleicht im Umfeld
einer bestimmten Krankheit bewegen
oder sich eben auch
wissenschaftlicher Quellen bedienen.
Wer krank ist,
kann in Social Media oder speziellen Foren
Erfahrungen mit anderen austauschen.
Es gibt nützliche Tipps,
aber auch hier ist Skepsis angebracht.
Gespräche in Social Media über
Gesundheitsfragen führen wir dort schriftlich.
Die Schrift verleitet schnell zu der Annahme,
diese Informationen könnten
eine besondere Güte haben,
eine besondere Qualität,
eine besonders starke Aussagekraft haben.
Aber wir müssen uns klarmachen,
dass das nicht der Fall ist.
Alleine auf Instagram erscheinen jeden Tag
viele Millionen neue Fotos.
Dass es sich dabei nicht immer
um seriöse Informationen handeln kann,
liegt eigentlich auf der Hand.
Wachsamkeit ist sicherlich
einer der zentralen Ratschläge
im Umgang mit Gesundheitsinformationen –
vor allen Dingen dann,
wenn ich sie online erhalten habe,
aber selbst auch dann, wenn ich sie
aus Expertenhand entgegengenommen habe.
Erst das Zusammenspiel im Kontext –
Was hat diese Information
konkret mit mir zu tun?
Gibt es noch zweite oder dritte Meinungen?
Gibt es noch weitere Quellen,
mit denen ich mich auseinandersetzen kann?
macht uns gesundheitskompetenter.
Und hier unsere wichtigsten Tipps:
Von wem stammt die Information,
welche Ziele verfolgt sie?
Auf welche Quellen stützt sich die Aussage,
gibt es Studien?
Wie alt ist die Information,
wird sie regelmäßig aktualisiert?